- I'm Chris Cotton here at
Comic Con 2018, San Diego
showing off my super power
which is telling people
what their super power could be.
This is Plausible
Power Generator.
Do I get any cool effects?
I think I should get some cool
effects comin' off my face.
(upbeat music)
- What super power
would you want?
- Flight.
- What does your mum always
scream about you doing?
What do you always
get in trouble for?
- Not taking out the trash.
- You could hop on a trash
bag and fly wherever you want,
do you like this power?
- Yes.
- But you always have
to take out the trash,
that's the only thing.
You have to take
out the trash now.
- Okay then.
- Remember, the juice
from the trash bag
does drip onto the ground,
so you will soil the
people underneath you.
- That's good.
- If you could have
any super power,
what would it be?
- Immortality.
- And what is your worst trait?
- Probably that
I'm cold-hearted.
- You're a little cold, okay.
So what your power be is,
whenever you're mean to
somebody, you become mortal.
But as long as you're
nice to people,
you have immortality.
- Well I'm dead.
(laughing)
- If you could have a super
power what would it be?
- That's a tough one.
Probably to cure
any known disease.
- Next question, what is
the trait that people say
is like kinda your worst trait?
What do you think it will be?
- Humility is obviously
my worst trait.
- Humility is his worst trait.
Okay, you will be able to
cure someone's disease,
but for the next 24 hours you
have to have that disease.
- I'd take it.
- So what do you think
I should add to my diet?
I mean, I should
just fix some things,
I'm doin' some
things wrong here.
- It's not add, it's take away.
- No I wanna add something.
I wanna--
So, time,
fly,
- Fly, yeah.
- Fly and invisibility.
Okay, now next question.
What is your worst trait?
What is your trait
that people say,
oh, you could fix this,
you could become better.
- Procrastination.
- Organizing.
- Too damn hyper man.
- So you need to calm down?
- Need to slow down,
need to calm it down.
- Your super power would be that
you can only affect time
when you're meditating.
Yes.
- I took yoga and
that was a mess.
So this is gonna be hard for me.
- Organization?
- Yes.
- You cannot fly until you're
house is completely clean.
- Oh my gosh.
- I'll be fine a
couple months from now.
I'll see you guys.
- You will go invisible.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Eventually, you
gotta wait for it.
- Yeah, eventually
I gotta wait for it.
- You gotta wait.
Are we doin' it?
Are we selfie?
Are we in selfie mode?
I heard you're a vegan,
that's a pretty awful trait.
Now if I had to
give you a power,
what your power would be,
anything that comes in front
of you that enters your mouth
it automatically becomes vegan.
That's it, you don't have
to ruin dinners anymore.
So you can only time travel,
when you're doing
something good.
- Yes.
- Basically if you're
about to win a game,
you never see the
end of the game.
You never get the satisfaction.
You could teleport but
only when you get annoyed.
- So I'm gonna get so upset
that I need to
teleport outta here.
- Yeah and you can't
fake it either.
Like you gotta be
really in your heart.
Your powers are awful.
- I guess so.
- But I mean--
- But at least I got
powers, that's what matters.
- What's the worst trait
that thing that people
don't really love
about you too much?
- I'm slop-ish.
- You're slavish?
- Slop-ish.
- You're slop-ish?
You're very sloppy?
Every time you make something
messy another room gets clean.
Only bad thing about this is
when you clean a room
you dirty up a room.
Half of your life is a mess,
the other half is clean.
It's the duality of man.
- Wow.
- Deep isn't it?
- That's a--
- It's deep.
I'm outta here.